en este problema nos están pidiendo que
encontremos el valor de la sección bs y
aquí podemos ver que tenemos diferentes
triángulos aquí adentro así que
seguramente vamos a necesitar establecer
similitudes entre estos tres triángulos
que vemos acá este triángulo este
triángulo y este otro triángulo grande
de acá para establecer la similitud
quizás tengamos que usar la proporción
para poder encontrar este valor de acá
si observamos con cuidado vemos que acá
tenemos un ángulo recto que es el que
está formado por bbc y el triángulo
formado por abc tiene aquí otro ángulo
recto y aquí tenemos otro conjunto de
ángulos correspondientes que son
congruentes entre sí de manera que
podemos mostrar que son similares aquí
podemos ver que los triángulos abc y bd
se comparten este mismo ángulo acá el
ángulo que está aquí en el vértice ce y
que vamos a poner en un color diferente
usamos este color
ambos triángulos comparten este ángulo
de aquí y sabemos que si tenemos 23
los que tienen al menos dos ángulos
congruentes
entonces estos triángulos van a ser
similares muy bien vamos a escribir aquí
que el triángulo a bs triángulo a b c
vamos del ángulo que no tiene etiqueta
va hacia el ángulo recto color amarillo
y luego al ángulo color naranja creo que
queda mejor si lo pongo en los mismos
colores el ángulo sin etiqueta el ángulo
recto en amarillo y el ángulo en naranja
aquí tenemos que ser cuidadosos de
escribir los ángulos y los vértices en
el mismo orden en ambos triángulos
queremos asegurarnos de tener la
similitud de manera correcta así que el
triángulo que va desde el vértice blanco
hacia el vértice con el ángulo recto en
amarillo y el ángulo en naranja va a ser
similar al triángulo que comienza en el
vértice que no tiene ni el ángulo recto
ni el ángulo naranja así que va a ser el
vértice b aunque no se confundan este
vértice b comparte un ángulo recto con
el triángulo más grande pero está
analizando el triángulo pequeño así que
comenzamos con el ángulo b luego vamos
al ángulo de 90 grados que en ese
triángulo pequeño es el ángulo d
y finalmente nos queda el ángulo ce el
ángulo naranja y ahora tenemos ambos
triángulos ordenados de manera similar
mostrando su similitud vamos a analizar
esto con detenimiento conocemos cuál es
la longitud del segmento a c 6 + 28 así
que ya conocemos el lado a c ahora cuál
es el lado correspondiente en el
triángulo más pequeño a este bueno ya
que los tenemos en el mismo orden
aquí está hace pues va a corresponder a
bs así que aquí abajo escribimos hace
entre bs
esto está interesante aquí ya incluimos
el término que estamos buscando bc ahora
si ubicamos el segmento bc en el
triángulo más grande vamos a tener que
va a corresponder al segmento
del triángulo más pequeño aquí está
escribimos veces entre dc y aquí vemos
que conocemos el valor del segmento de c
voy a tomar un paso adicional para
mostrarles cómo vamos a resolver el
valor de bs este paso es observar que el
segmento b c d nuestro triángulo más
grande corresponde al segmento de ce del
triángulo más pequeño en esta otra parte
de la igualdad vemos que el lado bc del
triángulo más grande corresponde al lado
de ce del triángulo más pequeño
indicamos aquí estas partes de arriba
corresponden al triángulo más grande y
estas partes de aquí abajo corresponden
al triángulo más pequeño y este problema
está genial porque vemos que el mismo
lado b se está tomando dos diferentes
papeles en ambos lados de la igualdad
ahora vamos a sustituir valores
conocemos que el valor de acs 86 más 2
es 8 conocemos el valor del lado de ce
que es 2 y ahora vamos a hacer una
multiplicación cruzada 8 por 2 16
a veces por veces es veces al cuadrado
por lo que nos queda que veces va a ser
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 16 así que
veces es igual a 4 veces es igual a 4 y
hemos terminado lo más difícil en este
problema era darse cuenta de que este
lado b se juega dos papeles en esta
igualdad y tener los conceptos muy
claros en nuestra mente para dejar más
claro todo esto voy a volver a dibujar
estos triángulos de manera separada así
que el triángulo más grande se verá más
o menos así este es mi triángulo a b c
este es nuestro ángulo recto aquí está
nuestro ángulo de color naranja y la
longitud de este lado de aquí es 8 la
longitud de este lado de acá encontramos
que era 4
y ahora vamos a dibujar nuestro otro
triángulo más pequeño b de c que va a
quedar más o menos así este es nuestro
lado b d
aquí dibujamos nuestro ángulo recto aquí
está nuestro ángulo naranja aquí este
lado vale 4 este lado vale 2 y lo dibujé
de esta manera para que puedan ver que
haría falta voltearlo y rotarlo para que
se note que son triángulos similares
para evitar confusiones yo les invito a
que hagan esta prueba de voltear y rotar
de manera que ambos triángulos queden
similares y se note bien esta proporción